now that we have
a larger sample size
we can talk about what is not just
something they'll try maybe
but what is clearly the new
electoral strategy to the extent that we
can even call it a strategy
from the modern republican party
and that strategy or maybe the the right
word for it would be more of a tactic
is to call an election rigged to say
that there was fraud
before we actually even know the results
we started to see this with donald trump
months before the 2020 presidential
election and of course it has become
essentially the story told by
republicans about the 2020 election it
was rigged it was fraud mail-in ballots
massive dumps of ballots we need
forensic audits there were bamboo fibers
there was too much barbecue sauce on the
papers there was not enough okay maybe
not that last one but you get the point
this is the story it's the election
wasn't fair trump should be president
that's the story being told by the right
and then
we saw the exact same thing
with larry elder
in advance of this week's california
gubernatorial recall let's go i know
i've played these clips already this
week
but let's go to larry elder being asked
by jacob sauberoff will you commit to
accepting the results of this election
this was the day before the recall again
whether or not you win or lose will you
accept the results of the election
tomorrow i think we all ought to be
looking at election integrity no matter
whether you're a democrat an independent
or republican let's all make sure that
the election is a fair election so this
all work together no matter what the
results are to make sure that the
results are valid and legitimate and
everybody who voted should have voted
let's all do that together is that a
commitment to accept the results of the
election tomorrow let's all do that
together let's all work together uh on
both sides of the aisle to make sure
that the election is a fair election we
know that's very familiar it's very
familiar for a reason and then also
here was donald trump doing the same
thing on newsmax an extra week earlier
as well got the recall election coming
up in less than a week it's actually
happening as we speak the polls appear
to show newsome look safer at this point
larry elder is the man that could take
it from him what do you think happens in
california
well it's probably rigged they're
sending out all ballots it's all uh the
the ballots are you know mail out
mail-in ballots in fact i guess you even
have a case where you can make your own
ballot when that happens uh
nobody's gonna win except uh these
democrats so you know look they're
they're very good the one thing they're
good at is rigging elections so i
predict it's a rigged election let's see
how it turns out so this is now a
strategy and none of this is surprising
there is a very good washington post
article about this
former president trump's uh false voter
fraud claims found new life
in california's biggest election this
year
the top republicans seeking to replace
governor gavin newsom in tuesday's
recall declined before the election to
say whether he would accept the results
a website affiliated with his campaign
invites visitors to sign a petition to
stop the fraud of the california recall
election and a previous version of the
site published before the election took
place blamed voter fraud for newsome
being quote reinstated as governor now
it's funny to even say reinstated he was
never removed
the article goes on to explain of course
there is no evidence for these claims
which have nonetheless been amplified
repeatedly by trump but their arrival in
the country's largest blue state offered
proof of their currency within the
republican party where some leaders have
increasingly sought to undermine public
confidence in democratic victories
that's an understatement by baselessly
alleging that elections are vulnerable
to
manipulation
um it does mention with newsome
projected to defeat the recall elder
conceded the race early wednesday
morning telling his audience to be
gracious in defeat
but the campaign tactics leading up to
the vote including open threats to raise
doubts about the results in case of
defeat suggest the possibility of a new
normal where republicans challenge
election losses even in heavily
democratic states without proof of
serious fraud or rule breaking
this is going to be the strategy
now none of it should surprise us
it is number one straight out of trump's
playbook elder is essentially a trump
clone agreeing with trump on just about
everything if a republican wins the
election then we can trust the results
everything is as it should be no fraud
took place
if they lose then it's rigged and this
is going to be i believe their mo from
here on out and not only is this
concerning
because it is the next step in
republicans completely abandoning trying
to win on issues i'm not going to give
you the whole story that noam chomsky
and i discussed of how this came to be
because it goes all the way back to the
civil rights movement
and and that era but
recently at least as recent history is
concerned as far as recent history is
concerned
we saw
particularly in the obama era and
obviously when trump ran
trump pretended to be about policy when
he ran
although they were all completely
unrealistic policy promises based on
misstatements about the world right um a
completely bogus promise to build a wall
across the entire southern border with
mexico that mexico would pay for
based on lies about the immigration
situation so the the framework was lies
and the proposed solution was never
going to happen he was never going to
build that wall mexico was never going
to pay for it but it was like pretending
to be about policy to the 2020 election
not even pretending to be about policy
that's marjorie taylor green that's
madison cawthorne that's lauren bobert
they don't even pretend to be about
policy and then the next step is despite
not actually
doing policy or
campaigning on policy
when you lose you say that it was rigged
this is very authoritarian it is very
authoritarian and it's a very dangerous
new status quo if that's indeed what is
what it's going to be and you know what
the signal was that they were going to
do it
in 2016 trump won
electorally and still didn't accept the
results of the popular vote remember he
said hillary clinton didn't even really
win the popular vote she won because of
millions of illegal immigrants that
voted and or you know people from
massachusetts were being bussed up to
new hampshire to vote of course ignoring
the fact that none of those
massachusetts people would be registered
to vote in new hampshire they wouldn't
be able to vote in new hampshire but
every election now is going to be
fraudulent
until and unless there start to be
consequences for telling that lie time
after time after time and um it is
i i don't think i have to explain this
to you but there's also the
it's not even a hypocrisy it's sort of
like a conflict between
they claim
that
i guess the democratic party although
think about the number of people that
would need to be involved they claim the
democratic party is smart enough
uh to
manufacture millions of fraudulent votes
and get away with it
but they don't actually put the votes in
places
where it would have a bigger effect on
the race like it just none of it makes
sense and with regard to trump there's
one other aspect to this
narcissists can't admit to being wrong
so when the polling data started to show
trump's going to lose elder is going to
lose
particularly with elder recently they
started the campaign well if they win
it's because they've stolen it if they
win it's because it's rigged
because they can't just say we just we
were just wrong
california didn't want to remove gavin
newsom we we miscalculated we were wrong
they have to go to it was actually fraud
and then maybe the most insidious and
scary part
which maybe they're not competent enough
for
is that this could end up being part of
a cry wolf strategy
claim that there's fraud when there
isn't in a whole bunch of races where
they lose
then they commit the fraud in some
future election
and then when democrats say guys there
was real fraud here
then they brush it off and they say guys
we everybody's sick of these claims of
fraud just accept that these are the
results i hope that that doesn't happen
because they're not organized enough to
do it but that's a scary aspect of this
as well
one of our sponsors is curiosity stream
the only subscription streaming service
just for documentaries my girlfriend and
i have been using the curiosity stream
platform at home non-stop i can tell you
from personal experience much better
documentary selection than netflix hulu
or amazon on curiositystream i'm always
finding documentaries by the world's
best filmmakers stuff you can't find on
other streaming services last month they
added a ton of awesome new titles to the
library i just finished watching
becoming martian
about the future of the human species
and its possible path through mars but
there's documentaries on every topic
imaginable science nature history
politics if you love documentaries the
way i do you are not going to find a
better source of brand new award-winning
docs anywhere else curiosity stream is
giving my audience 25 off that means you
can subscribe for just 15 bucks a year
very reasonable considering the endless
number of super quality documentary
content that you have access to
just go to
curiositystream.compacman the link is
right underneath this video